بك خير الخلق
كلهم مولاي صل وس
دائما ابدا على
حبيبك خير الخلق
كل مولا يا صلي وسلم
دائما
ابدا
حبيبك خير
الخلق محمد سيد الكونين
والثقلين
والفريقين من عرب ومن عجب مولاي صل وسلم
دائما على
حبيبك خير الخلق
كلهم مولاي صل وسلم
دائما ابدا على
حبيبك خير
الخلق اه هو
الحبيب الذي ترجى
شفاعته لكل هول من الاهوال
مقتحم مولاي صلي وسلم
دائما ابدا على
حبيبك خير الخلق
كل مولا ص وسلم
دائما ابدا على
حبيبك خير
الخلق اه فق
النبينا في خلق وفي خلق ولم يدانوه في جود
ولا كرم مولاي صل وسلم
دائما سك خير الخلق
كل مولاي صل وسلم
دائما على
حبيبك
خير اه دع الى الله فالمستمسكون
به دع الى الله فالمستمسكون
به مستمسكون
بحبل الغير
معتصم مولاي صل وسلم
دائما ابدا على
حبيبك خير الخلق
كله مولاي صل
وسلم ابدا على
حبيبك خير
الخلق اه
ثم عن ابي بكر وعن عمر ثم الرضى عن ابي
بكر وعن عمر وعن علي وعن عثمان ذ الكرم
مولاي صلي وسلم
دائما ابدا على
حبيبك خير
الخلق مولاي صل وسلم
دائما ابدا على
حبيبك خير الخلق
كلهم يا رب بالمصطفى بلغ
مقاصدنا يا رب بالمصطفى بلغ
مقاصدنا واغفر لنا ما مضى واغفر لنا ما
مضى اغفر لنا ماضى يا واسع الكرم مولاي صل
وسلم
دائما ابدا على
حبيبك خير الخلق
كله مولاي صلي وسلم
دائما ابدا على
حبيبك خير الخلق كلهم